bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you're
subscribed to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to eight point six percent
apy in an interest bearing account or
you can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral you can use the description
right here
or you can go to blockfi.com to learn
more
all right let's get into this episode i
hope you guys enjoy this one
all right guys bang bang i've got a
visual here thank you so much for doing
this sir
great to see you thanks for having me
for sure let's just jump into your
background uh you didn't
work on crypto forever so what did you
do before crypto
uh where'd you grow up uh facebook just
tell the whole story
yeah uh well where i grew up um i grew
up i was born in india i grew up mostly
in the midwest
like kentucky and ohio um then came out
west for school and um
spent most my career as an entrepreneur
so i started and sold two companies
um second one to facebook um and
worked on a bunch of stuff there worked
on products and and some ad stuff and
had a good time
um and uh with that second company
actually the way i got into crypto with
that second company
um what we were doing was we were kind
of like um
uh we were actually kind of like a tivo
in the cloud so you gave us the url we
copy whatever's on the other side of it
and make a copy of it
but the way that we did that was we
built all of this really amazing
infrastructure
where we could control computers and all
sorts of remote data centers we kind of
built our own little mini distributed
system
and and we're able to cost optimize that
um and and like buy remnant compute
power all over the world
and um this was in like 2010 2011
and my co-founder curtis uh was also my
co-founder at electric
uh he worked on uh protein folding at
home he worked on like some distributed
systems like
15 years ago and uh he came across
bitcoin and said hey i think this
actually might solve the hardest problem
we had which was like how do you get
people to donate
computational resources to to this
network like this bitcoin thing might
solve it
and so uh for a hot minute we said maybe
we should just become bitcoin
miners so in like 20 2011 we just
started like mining a bunch of bitcoin
um
it was like pre-asic era right and so um
2010 2011
and um and we were we were not pressing
it we were not visionaries we didn't
hang on to it so we like you know
there there was a period ran up to like
you know 100 bucks or whatever and we
basically just sold it like this is
insane we're out
um and uh but that was kind of like our
original foray into it and then facebook
bought all that ip
and then we stuck around as obvious and
so we did a little bit of like ethereum
and monero mining
um and um and then we left in 2016
um and we're thinking about what to do
and we're just spending all of our time
in crypto personally
um we were you know it was kind of like
the first thing that felt as raw as the
internet felt
to us um when we were kids where you
just like going to a chat room and
nobody knew
how old you were where you lived you
know who you were it was just like your
handle
and you had some ideas and you like
threw them out there and if they made
sense and like people engaged with you
and and if they didn't make sense you
got ignored
um and you kind of had this like just
amazing experience i'm sure you remember
this from like 2017 where
you would um you'd show up in a in a
chat room or telegram group or a signal
or whatever
and um and it would be you know like
this motley crew of people like
like the group of people in crypto even
to today i think it's like you know wall
street people you have
entrepreneurs you have um academics you
have touring award winners you have
professors that have dropped out of
school you have college kids
um you have like adult film stars you
you you know obviously you have some
drug dealers
but like that's a really strange group
of people to all be in one place
um and you know if you threw a dinner
like if you do a house party and that
was who showed up you'd be like what the
hell house party is this right like i
got some porn stars and some drug
dealers and like
my college professor and like a bunch of
college kids and like some wall street
guys it's just be like a weird party
so it could be fun it could be a blast
right well it is a blast right i mean
that's what makes crypto really fun it's
just like
all these people on the fringe kind of
like showed up to the same party
and um so we looked at in 2017 and we
were like this is so fun we just want to
do this all day so we threw
we just threw down some desks at my
place and um
and curtis would come over every day and
we would like be in these chat rooms
we'd be reading white papers and
we're hacking on some code and writing
some smart contractors having fun with
it
and um uh kind of as the last bitcoin
cycle was going up
all these vcs started reaching out to us
um because we
we had done some companies so a bunch of
folks know us and so they started
reaching out saying hey
um could you come in and talk to the
partnership about this crypto stuff like
i remember you guys telling me about
bitcoin like five years ago six years
ago is it real this time
should i like should i buy some bitcoin
what's eth what's it what's an ico
uh you know like uh should i do one like
how do i you know should this company do
one and so we started doing all this
education
in 2017 and by the end of 2017 all these
people
um a bunch of the the more traditional
vcs who are phenomenal i mean these are
like
the world's best investors really
quickly realize that crypto is different
and they're not really set up to do it
um you have like regulatory challenges
you don't want to go register with the
sec
um you know back then it's a lot better
now but you know four years ago if you
if you invest in some token network like
what all of a sudden one day like a usb
stick shows up with five million dollars
on it like
what do you do with that is your
associate just hang on to that at their
house like that doesn't seem like a good
idea right
so they were like okay we don't want to
do this can we just give you guys money
like if i if i give you money of each
line curtis i know
you're not gonna go buy some monero and
like move to costa rica and like
live that john mcafee life right so here
take some money
and like do what you do and just like
you know we trust you guys and so that's
that's actually how electric happened
um so curtis and i joke we're kind of
like accidental vcs we never
we were like entrepreneurs that were
just kind of doing our thing and a bunch
of people
said hey take some money and i i mean
anybody who's done a company is like if
people show up with money and they're
like hey take our money you should
probably take it like we've been
we lived through 2008 and so like one of
the number one lessons we learned is
like if people want to give you money
you should probably take it
um and so that's how we started electric
and and now we focus 100 on crypto
um and crypto networks and and uh have
been fortunate to be able to do that for
the last few years
so uh you are my favorite accidental vc
which goes right next to my favorite
non-vc which is jeff lewis at bedrock
who uh who continues to everyone that so
we've got accidental vcs we have not a
vc and i'm sure that somebody will call
us something new
uh talk through just a little bit about
kind of your thesis on
crypto in general right so there's some
major themes that i think you guys have
but just
when you sit down with an lp and you say
hey you know here's how we think about
this space here's why we're excited
about it
what do you share with them yeah um
so we i mean we're we're engineers and
like product people and so we came at it
from like a really different perspective
i think there's this
really valid which we learned just just
by doing
um world view on this stuff which is a
little bit more top down right which is
like the
money supply fixed supply austrian
school of economics like all that kind
of stuff
that we sort of um you know we we
bootstrapped up into to understand but
we come at it from like a much more
bottoms up perspective like our
our take on it is is through the lens of
software
and so what you have here is in our
opinion
um the pendulum swinging away from the
internet like the internet as we know it
today
which is like if you think about what
the internet was designed to do or what
has become
it really optimizes for like speed and
throughput and scalability
um and what we gave up were things like
privacy
um as we've now realized the ownership
of our data
and hand over control to these like
massive centralized organizations
and you know these crypto networks and
all this distributed technology all of a
sudden just says
what happens if i do the opposite like
instead of optimizing for speed and
scalability and throughput
what if i optimize for you owning your
own data and what if i optimize for
censorship resistance and what if i
optimize for
privacy like what can i do um and once
you change the constraint set like that
um it's there it's sort of that like
marshall mcluhan the the medium as a
message kind of a thing right it's like
actually the once you change the
constraints people just become really
creative and you realize you can do
totally different things
and so the question then is okay we have
this technology stack that basically
does
this totally different set of things on
the internet it's the inverse of the
internet
um so what is it good for um and i think
the failing that most people have had is
they look at it
and they say oh it's bad at all these
things instead of saying like what is it
good for so it reminds me a little bit
of like
um uh the iphone launch like i was i was
actually really fortunate i slept
outside moscone to be able to get into
that iphone launch and i watched steve
jobs like launch the iphone it was just
a sick just like an unbelievable it was
a master class and like how you do a
product launch it was unbelievable
um but the the thing that i remember
afterwards was like i went back to work
and i tried to like
explain to people this thing that had
just happened um
and i couldn't i just like totally
failed to explain it and the criticisms
were like hey because the blackberry was
so dominant at the time the criticisms
were like
oh it doesn't have a keyboard and like
you know like
it doesn't let me do this or you know
the screen is really small or the
internet connection is slow or there's
no apps like there are all these
criticisms
and what people totally missed were like
oh well it has a gps on the device it
has a pretty good camera
and the touch screen lets you just do
totally different things um and so i
think if you look at the
the sort of blockchain and crypto
universe the question is what is all
this stuff really good for like where
does privacy matter
where is it okay if things don't happen
in like 30 milliseconds if it takes a
couple of minutes like where is that
okay
and it turns out anything that deals
with money those are actually
very reasonable trade-offs to make like
you don't need to get a loan
in like 30 milliseconds especially if
like you think about how you get a loan
today from the bank um
it might take you 30 days it might take
you 60 days so actually like 30 minutes
to get a loan or three minutes to get a
loan is still
way better it's orders of magnitude
better than 30 days
um and so what you have is this like
technology that's just good at a totally
different set of stuff than the internet
and a massive market which is everything
to do with money that the
technology is just a perfect fit for um
and so to us that's like that's where
all this starts and so that's you know
like our understanding of bitcoin and
our understanding of ethereum really
came kind of more like bottoms up
and then we sort of like learned about
the economic side of it we're like oh
this is kind of like digital gold
um but to us it's like the technology
that's always been the interesting wedge
yeah so let's talk a little bit just
about kind of decentralization in
general i think that this is probably
one of the underlying themes across you
know a lot of what you guys are doing
and really just
the industry in general and so there's
kind of a couple schools of thought one
is hey
bitcoin is the king bitcoin will remain
the king and everything will be built on
top of bitcoin uh there's another school
of thought that is
um we're gonna take all of the ethos of
bitcoin around decentralization
uh make kind of consensus and we're
gonna go apply it in a million different
ways with all sorts of different
technology
and go touch every other industry and
then there's kind of
a hybrid which is like well bitcoin's
gonna be really important and
uh that's likely to be the winner in the
digital currency space and then like
there's a bunch of other stuff but they
don't necessarily compete with bitcoin
my guess is that you're in the third
bucket but one i want to make sure that
that's true and then just kind of
explain like everything else
other than bitcoin uh as you're kind of
thinking through decentralization into
the protocols
yeah we're absolutely in that third
bucket like bitcoin is the biggest and
most important protocol
today it will be one of the biggest and
most important things in this entire
space
it's the gateway drug for a lot of
people it's like how you get into the
space is you
you sort of get your head around bitcoin
um
and then once you start getting your
head around bitcoin you start realizing
that there there are
some things that bitcoin's phenomenal
for and great for and then actually
if you sort of just tweak the
consideration set a little bit or the
constraints a little bit you might be
able to do more and so
something as simple as like yes
technically you know there's bitcoin
script and it's programmable
um not quite the way that other
platforms are but like wouldn't it be
great if it were much easier for
developers to come in and write these
kinds of smart contracts
um and and that very naturally starts to
lead you to something like ethereum
um or hey wouldn't it be great if
actually um
you could um tweak uh some of the
parameters and and make it much much
better for like micro payments
like east has has some challenges around
gas fees um
and that might lead you to something
like um like mobile point which is
really optimized for payment flows and
so um you can start i think
bitcoin's really really important but we
sort of think that there's going to be
many many thousands of tokens they're
going to be many many thousands of
protocols
um and they're going to all sort of
interact with each other um and we're
going to essentially
recreate a lot of in our opinion what
the internet was supposed to be and but
it'll take 20 to 30 years like i think
we're like in the first first ending of
this
um so i'm happy to talk about that i
mean i think that the sort of natural
one that we we spend a lot of time on
these days
is um is essentially the smart contract
universe like
you know i think one of the most
fundamental things here that most people
even people in the space including
ourselves i think
have not really fully internalized is
what it means
for computers to be able to own money
right so like if you start from this
place of
um you know bitcoin is money like
the bits themselves are the value um
that's kind of a crazy concept right
that's it's a bearer instrument that
that means
you know unlike your bank account when
you go to your bank
um that's a representation of money like
you log in and then you gotta go to the
bank it's really an iou from the bank
um and um which is really it's funny
because then that's an iu from the
government
um but uh you know bitcoin is different
because you own the bits and if you own
the bids
you know you own the money and the way
that you assert ownership over the bits
is with a private key
um which is just another set of bits and
so very quickly you realize well
doesn't that mean that like a piece of
code can create a wallet
and and have its own private key and it
never tells me what the private key is
and then i can send money into the
wallet and actually now that piece of
code essentially custodies the money it
owns the money
um and that's a pretty fundamental
breakthrough because what that means is
that
computers can be counterparties to
humans and there doesn't need to be a
human on the other side
or what it means is that actually
computers like machines can pay machines
and so once you start playing that out
you're like wait so that means like you
could do really crazy
stuff eventually things like you have a
self-driving car driving down the street
and enough of them line up and they like
all decide to pay the stop light to turn
green
so you can do like micro transactions
and actually now like all the lights in
the city would turn
um green kind of at the right you know
at the right times and like your traffic
will flow more
swiftly and actually you'll be gathering
taxes exactly for the streets whether
it's the most usage
right like that kind of stuff you're
like oh that could actually now happen
and there need to be no humans in the
loop like you just
the way you go to the gas station maybe
you like plug in your car to charge
and like using your mobile app you like
fill up the wallet on your car's
um wallet right um that kind of crazy
stuff can start to happen
but in the short term um you start
saying well you know what are these
things really good for
and in our opinion um going back to this
idea of like
money um smart contracts are this really
interesting thing because what they do
is they take like
a quadrillion dollars of stuff that's
happening in the world
and allow you to express it in code and
so if you think about anything that has
to do with money right a will or a trust
or an escrow
or a re or a mortgage or a security or a
derivative like literally
a quadrillion dollars of the world is
here's a pile of money
and here's a bunch of rules around that
money like you know anthony has access
to it a veto doesn't
but like in six months a vital has
access to it and anthony does it so like
in
in some future time horizon like please
execute these instructions and today we
just do that with like spreadsheets and
legal documents and
email and like that's actually how all
of that stuff works today
and so along comes something like
ethereum which is just like well i can
own the money
and now you can just write those
instructions out in code and it's
deterministic like i can tell you
exactly what the code is going to do and
there's no way to change it
and that's that's literally the one
thing that computers are better than
humans at is like deterministically
executing instructions
so to us it's just like you know
literally a quadrillion dollars of stuff
is going to get eaten up by these kinds
of
of tools um how it happens and stuff you
know i think it's going to take a decade
to play out we're still in the really
early days i mean we very well
you know using a facebook analogy we
very well may be in the like myspace era
of this
where we kind of are starting to see
that this is possible but actually like
we haven't realized how it's going to go
mainstream yet
um or maybe if you're in this facebook
we will know in 10 years
um but you know i think i think we
haven't yet really figured out how this
stuff is going to change everybody's
lives and it
i think it's going to change everybody's
lives i think it's going to touch seven
billion people
so i completely agree with you how do
you think about like let's just take
smart contract
platforms in general right so i think
ethereum is by far the leader there
um there's a bunch of people working on
bringing smart contract functionality to
bitcoin uh but then there's also you
know a gazillion other it seems uh smart
contract platforms
uh that are popping up that really you
know ethereum killers competition what
however you want to
kind of label them but how do you think
about this is it a one smart contract
platform to rule them all is there
coexistence
uh is it literally every protocol will
have to have smart contract
compatibility and so
it's less about like which one is the
smart contract platform and it's just
like at what point does a protocol add
that functionality just like how do you
think about that among the different
protocols yeah i think um it's
a really good question and it's a tough
question and there's a different
question
there's like a slightly there's two
different questions there there's the
question of like what happens in the
world
uh and what do you think is going to
happen in the world and then there's the
like investor variant of that question
which is like okay
well then how do you construct a
portfolio you know to minimize your
downside but maximize your upside and
you might do something slightly
different like you might be really
convinced that
ethereum is going to win but as a as a
you know that might be like a 90
chance you're like okay i just think
ethereum's gonna win but as an investor
you might still
take a bunch of positions into things
you know to just in case right from a
from a return perspective it might still
make sense to do that
so the first question like i think the
way it's going to
likely play out is it's going to be
winner takes most because the network
effects are real
um you know developer network effects
integration network effects fiat
on-ramps and op-ramps regulatory network
effects like these are all things that
are remotes
around a layer one protocol and ethereum
far and away has the lead there
but it's still very early days um and
then i think you'll get like number two
number three number four
um and depending on how you think about
it as an investor that could still be a
fantastic opportunity
so if you look at like social networking
which is another network effect driven
um sort of uh business um facebook was
obviously the big winner but
linkedin did fantastically twitter is
really important tic toc is really
important snap
is really important like you you
actually have if the market size is like
large enough is it you know it's
multiple billions of people
then odds are you can have second and
third and fourth place winners that are
still really really massive
um and so i don't think it's i don't
think it's um you know winner take
all i think it's winner take most but
actually we're in such early days here
that actually from an investor
perspective kind of having
having a few different bets you'll
probably still do really well if you
pick well
um and then each of those networks will
specialize in the same way that media
companies or the social media companies
or other network effect
things do um and so you might get one
thing that's sort of the the money chain
which might be like eve
you might get something that's much
better for nfts because like
you know scalability is such a challenge
and gas fees are so high that like
crowds that crowds out a lot of
non-functional token use cases
um and so maybe that just moves
somewhere else um and so you know i
think it's tbd how who wins and how they
win
um but i think that my best guess is
that's how it'll be it's like winner
take most
um and then specialized chains for for
different use cases that are optimized
to to meet the needs of that sort of
crowd people yeah i mean it makes sense
and you know the beauty of it is the
market will ultimately decide but i
think that that's a pretty rational view
of the world
let's look around you you talked a lot
about kind of the technology
infrastructure and kind of how that
plays out
um and really where investors are
thinking about capital and
returns but how does this look for users
in terms of how does the crypto
infrastructure
kind of change the products and services
and goods that we interact with on a
daily basis i think people understand
uh the argument for bitcoin as money
and that not being kind of fiat or kind
of in the traditional
technology format but what else like how
do you think about
the the actual everyday life of a uh
person somewhere in the world
changing because of this crypto
infrastructure yeah i think it's gonna
be
kind of like the phone in a sense which
is to say that um it's gonna change
everything
but you will stop thinking about it as a
separate thing
so like there was a time when people
were doing mobile apps where like
investors
would see pitch decks or founders would
go in and pitch and be like we're a
mobile app company
right and here's what we do and and like
if you did that today
your investors would just be like well
like of course you were like what else
would you be right like of course you're
a mobile company right
um and so i think that will that's kind
of how it will happen so the question is
like what are the use cases where people
are going to use these things and they
won't even realize that it's quickly
behind the scenes right
and then one day five or ten years from
now like every company will just have
this and it'll just make sense to use
these primitives
and then you won't even call them crypto
companies it'll just be that's just like
an app or that's just a company right
so a really concrete example would be
you know like facebook is doing this uh
what used to be called libra is now
called dm um which is the idea that you
could have this
this way to move uh money really really
quickly between people all over the
world
and of course that makes sense inside
something like facebook messenger or
whatsapp
um and in a lot of other use cases and
so like shopify is part of that network
um and then try to make that happen and
they have all sorts of challenges um but
you can imagine if they launched that
like all of a sudden a billion people
would be moving money around the world
using crypto infrastructure because
that's actually a better way to do this
stuff it's actually like the 2020s
computer science version of how do i
move money around the world
and sort of like 1970s infrastructure
which is kind of how we do it today
um and so i think that's how it plays
out or like another good way this is i
think gonna play out is like through the
creator economy
like creators are you know musicians and
artists and
um and all these people that are just so
creative about how they're using media
um and they're they're you're already
seeing starting to see it happen right
like what is it what does it mean
for a musician to like make music but
retain the rights to that music
right um is there a way for them to
essentially have like the the rights be
digital and be guaranteed that they own
them
but perhaps be able to resell them or
what does it mean for a creator to
uh be able to like uh raise money
right so creators are really interesting
creators are like the new small business
like
15 years ago if you were a sas business
and you went to a bank and you're like
hey look we have really good arr
will you lend us money the banks are
like no i don't that's not a that's like
not a physical asset how do i lend
against that they didn't understand this
concept of recurring revenue
how do you do that as like a youtube
creator or a tick tock creator today can
you go to a bank and be like hey i have
18 million
fans or followers like please lend me
money so i can like hire staff and make
better content and like
monetize better like no bank is going to
give you money right
because they don't understand that asset
but your fans might
right and so maybe what you can do is
like issue a token and your fans will
all buy that token
um and if you're if they find you when
you're when you're just starting out
and there's a limited number of tokens
and those tokens give you benefits like
you get to be a part of a
an invite-only fan club like maybe those
tokens appreciate in value over time
um and so when that when that creator is
really popular then those tokens are
worth a lot of money
um and so you know that you can and
creators are playing with this kind of
stuff today right
it becomes for the creator like a
financing mechanism and for the fans a
way to like
support the people that they create care
about but also potentially participate
in the
financial upside of identifying people
so you become like a talent scout
that's totally gonna happen um and very
well what will happen on crypto
infrastructure
it's just like people may not realize
that that's what they're doing behind
the scenes right so i think that's
that's kind of how it plays out is like
five over the next five years there will
just be some killer use cases
um and and the average person won't even
realize that what they're using is
crypto
and so those killer use cases i think i
separated them into two buckets right
one is like hey
uh amazon already has gift cards and so
that's a version of a
token it's got a different technology
form factor but uh it unlocks certain
types of behavior a certain value for
that ecosystem
the other would be something like hey
uber wouldn't have been possible without
mobile phones with gps in it and
therefore there was a technology leap
and then that unlocked
you know a whole bunch of services not
just uber but but many like it that use
that gps functionality
and so it almost sounds like you're
basically making the argument like both
will happen right it's not a binary
world like some of it is just taking
existing things in the world and now
using tokens and protocols and smart
contracts
to now put them in this new technology
form factor but also because there is
innovation around the technology that we
can unlock brand new use cases
uh and brand new things in the world
that we haven't seen before because of
that technology leap
yeah that's right and and i think um you
know there
are like a couple of different ways to
look at that so um
the historical analog is like if you go
back i went back
and um read a bunch of articles from
like the early 90s when the internet was
just getting off the ground and it's
they're hilarious
i totally if anybody is like uh like a
student of history you should totally go
back and read these articles because
like you see them trying to explain this
new thing the internet and they're just
like
to to now to us it's just like so
obvious but they're just that struggling
and so you have these like hilarious
videos and stuff that people trying to
explain the internet
and and the prevailing wisdom at one
point was
once people got their head around the
idea that that the internet was like the
information superhighway
the natural conclusion was oh well of
course this is going to be great for cnn
and the new york times like they're
going to be just huge businesses and
walmart is totally going to be
able to sell stuff online and be like an
even bigger company
and in retrospect you're like oh that
was totally wrong uh like the real
winners were facebook and youtube and
tiktok and twitter and amazon it was not
you know
the incumbents um and and the reason is
that
um like adopting this technology
natively and using it natively um
requires you to change the human
organization
around the technology right so like at
amazon
the people that make all the decisions
are the engineers not the brand managers
it's not the guy who has the
relationship with procter gamble that
gets to make the call
um and so the question in crypto land is
yeah like
all of this stuff gets baked in to
existing companies shopify and facebook
and
and whatever else um but like what does
a crypto native organization look like
and like what use cases does that
infrastructure unlock that you just
couldn't do before because
if you play that forward i mean amazon
was sort of an obvious one like in the
sense that like you could see e-commerce
was going to happen
um but a lot of the really biggest
businesses
that came out of the internet were the
things that were really
counter-intuitive
they like they just didn't make sense at
the time like it's hard to imagine now
but like
facebook facebook and airbnb and uber
just like made no sense at the time they
actually you know
like they're basically those the biggest
messages on the internet are like
basically all of the things you're not
supposed to do
right like you're not supposed to talk
to strangers you like shouldn't get into
strangers car
you feel like shouldn't go to a
stranger's house uh like really you're
gonna take everything about your life
like where you live and who you are and
who you're married to and like what your
kids look like and put it into a public
database where anybody can find you
like these are all the things you're not
supposed to do and they're like the
biggest businesses right
um so the question i i sort of think
through is like what is the wave of
stuff
where it's going to look really obvious
in hindsight but in the moment you're
like that looks batshit
like why would anybody do that um and
that's really hard but i think those are
going to be actually the really big
thing so there's like this set of
obvious stuff that we just talked about
like you know mobile payments um but i
think there's going to just be some
really really wild stuff that i don't
think we've like fully scratched the
surface of
um that that's going to start to happen
and the the other thing that is
important to realize is like that takes
time
you know like we didn't we didn't start
to see the counter-intuitive stuff on
the internet in some sense really
start to hit until like 15 years later
right like the internet really started
let's say 1990-ish
um like the really counter-intuitive
stuff was like 2005 is like people were
ready for it
um or like even with the iphone right
like the iphone happened
and the first version of the apps were
like skeuomorphic it was like leather
and paper and wood right it was just
because like it was touch so we're like
oh we're used to like touching wood so
we should make it look like wood um or
you know have like a gps
and so we could take like the desktop
maps and say like oh okay i can put a
map on a phone now we could like port it
over
um but it literally took like i think
uber was 2010
and so that means it took about three
years of people playing
around on the iphone for people to
figure out that like the killer app
was not that i could go somewhere but it
was that like other stuff could come to
me you had to like turn the idea on its
head
and that was actually the killer app for
gps um
and so like i think we're still like in
the very early days of this exploration
and it might it very well might take
like three to ten years for us to
stumble into a bunch of like really
counter-intuitive stuff
which just turns on its head the idea of
like any of what what we think is
possible today
and so that's like the really fun stuff
i mean you know this too is like a
venture investor it's like the stuff
that you
like you walk away from a meeting and
you're just like okay that was either
the stupidest thing i've ever heard or
that was brilliant and i don't know what
right like i don't know
it could be either one and they don't
know and that's like the really
interesting stuff in my opinion
so one of the things that the venture
capital community has figured out is
like
sometimes the best investment strategy
is like i'm gonna go find the smartest
people
that are going for the biggest markets
i'm just gonna give them money and like
why do i think i'm smarter than like
let's figure it out
uh when it comes to crypto and
decentralization
is the team or the person less important
because you're not talking about a
decentralized system they don't have
control
and kind of there's all these you know
new frameworks or paradigms
or actually is it still the same thing
when you think about allocating capital
like you're just looking for
really really smart people going after
unique problems or hard problems and
that's kind of a big
you know milestone or thing that you
look for when you're actually investing
yeah so i think at a high level that's a
great question because um
well because i think the real answer is
nobody knows yet actually right and
we'll find out in 10 years
that being said i think we tend to think
that that
valley creation follows great people and
so just like give people
give the best people the most money and
they'll do they'll do great things with
it
um that being said i think the challenge
is that the what like how do you define
great like what does it mean to be great
in crypto versus what does it mean to be
great on the internet
and um you know on the internet you had
people like jeff bezos or travis
kalanick or
mark zuckerberg create just huge amounts
of value um
and they had a certain archetype there's
a certain profile there there's a
certain set of skills
and i think what's interesting about
crypto is that um
the skill set is very different um and
so you have brilliant people like
vitalik
um but he operates totally differently
from zuck as
you know right like um and and there's
this sense of like
um what is that set of skills that it's
actually gonna take to be successful and
like a bunch of the people that move
over i think from the internet are
probably likely to fail even even if
they're super successful because goes
back to this idea of like what does it
mean to be a crypto native entrepreneur
um so it's actually i would say it's
probably the hardest part of my job
actually it's just like
you you meet these really really
brilliant people but you're not sure if
there's like founder market fit you're
like is this the kind of person that can
succeed in this market and that's sort
of a process that i think all the
investors and all the founders and
everybody's kind of trying to figure out
is like who are the kinds of people that
can really be successful here and why
um but i mean i think you can look at
somebody like vitalik and you're like i
don't know would he have been successful
like going through y combinator maybe
um but he's clearly clearly the right
type of person to be to be operating
crypto network and be sort of you know
the steward of that
yeah talk a little bit about uh
conversations with uh
limited partners or investors in your
fund uh and how that sentiment has
shifted over the years in terms of uh
2017 2018.
people sound like they were just like
literally throwing money at you like hey
you solve my problem i don't understand
this and then kind of how that
uh maybe went through a trough and then
has uh has recovered a little bit
yeah it's yes yeah it has um and in a
funny way
i think for crypto like covid was a
great catalyst like kobe kovad was
tailwind for netflix and amazon but also
code was great
tailwind for bitcoin um in part because
all these things that bitcoin people
have been saying and groups of people
have been saying
like hey look the money printing is just
gonna get worse they're not gonna dial
it down
um right and like this is gonna get
really bad and like you know um
we don't trust our institutions anymore
and like this is there are real problems
here like censorship is a problem like
all these things that the crypto people
have been saying for years and years
and and we all sounded like loonies all
of a sudden the lps that had heard these
people talking about these things sat up
one day and we're like wait maybe you're
right
um and that basically happened in like
march april and i think that was that
was a pretty pivotal moment
but even even before that you know i
think you have to kind of break down
like institutional investors into like
what kinds of institutional investors
and there are like large family offices
or ultra high net worths
um there are endowments there are
pension funds um
you know there are sovereign wealth
funds and so there's a spectrum there
um and you know like 2017 the people who
are
who are kind of clued into crypto i
would say were essentially
ultra ultra high net worths you know
like billionaires and some
some family offices and kind of where we
moved like where the dominoes have moved
to now
is like the endowments and like a very
small number of very forward-thinking
pension funds
um and corporate treasuries you know
folks like square or microstrategy
um and um but we're not yet like
sovereign wealth bonds we're not yet at
central banks like we're not there yet
um and so that's not where the line is
and i think um
you know the conversation the the big
shift basically has been that
every time like the best way to in my
opinion to like have lp set up and take
note
is if the person to their left just made
a bunch of money and so like what ended
up happening in like 2016 2017
was a bunch of billionaires had some
friend or a friend of a friend
who was like a you know 100 millionaire
and like that guy became a billionaire
and then they looked over and they're
like wait that guy's a billionaire like
how did that guy become a billionaire
and they started looking what he's doing
and and there was crypto in the mix and
then so all those people started buying
and then when those people started buy
in
the really large family office just
started to look over and then once the
really large family offices started to
look over
um you know endowments and pensions
started look over and so you kind of
have this like domino effect
um and we're just sort of like at this
point it's like we're far enough along
that
the rest of the diamonds are clearly
going to fall um you know the other
thing i'll say is i think
one of the big learnings for us too is
um even inside every sort of group of
lps
there are some people that are just way
more rational about it than others
um and so i've been really impressed to
the degree to which there are these like
really smart ultra rational investors
and when you meet them how quickly they
get it and like the three things that
those guys are
all into now that all those people are
into these like hyper rational smart
institutional folks
and they get um is crypto marijuana and
esports
it's like really interesting like they
get those things in a way that like a
lot of other institutional investors
don't
um and so you know if um
if if we were if we were talking to lp
like three or four years ago i think we
looked like crazy people
and like today you have the same
conversation and people like oh man like
you guys are you have like seen the
future it's like pretty dramatic how
quickly it changed too
i i always laugh and say you can go talk
to like any kid between ages like maybe
i don't know 15 and 25
and be like hey our electric vehicle is
going to be a thing like of course every
car is going to be electric
like hey is you know digital money gonna
be a thing like of course like what are
you talking about you know is esports
gonna be a thing of course
and so that there's this element of like
uh when i
talk to a bunch of institutional
investors a lot of them will literally
reference like
my kid is all into this right and like
it's driving them they hear them talking
about it and
for whatever reason they have this
inclination like my kid's probably right
my kid knows nothing about investing but
like my kid's probably right
uh it's i do think that that has a big
impact though right
that's hilarious yeah i mean that's
that's a fantastic investment thesis you
should just like
do what the young people are doing if
you just like bet long on that you'll
probably you'll probably do the right
thing
because all these things are gonna
happen and they're totally right the
other thing that i keep uh keep going
back to as well
is uh i've been fortunate enough as i'm
sure you have as well uh to talk to
some of the most successful investors in
the world um
and most of these folks are considered
the most successful because not only
have they had great returns but they've
been doing for a very long period of
time it's
just naturally with experience comes age
right and so they
they end up being in their 50 60
sometimes even older
and in almost every single situation
they have somebody who is younger than
them that has gotten them in right so
whether it is their child
a friend you know whatever it is and so
it's always fascinating to see
that uh in those conversations they'll
say something like oh you know my kid's
been like every single time i see him
like he's always just
pounding away at me about this stuff but
then all of a sudden they see market
prices move
and they say wait a second like maybe i
should spend more time here maybe
actually this is the right kind of
thesis and so
how do you think that that plays out not
only from a bitcoin sample because
everyone's paying attention to bitcoin
cnbc all the
the media organizations pay attention to
the bitcoin price but what about
everything else right when everything
else starts to kind of move up does that
further unlock even more capital than
just the bitcoin price
or do you think institutions yet aren't
paying attention to like the things
outside of bitcoin necessarily and so we
still got some way to go until they
start to really understand the rest of
it
yeah it's very early days for anything
that's not bitcoin it's um
you know when we talk to to institutions
i would say
the most forward-thinking ones look at
ethereum
and they think it's going to be a thing
kind of the way they thought bitcoin was
probably going to be a thing in the 2017
move and they have not yet made the
decision to move into it
um where we've had lots of conversations
with institutions that are trying to
figure out how to own bitcoin directly
um you know whether or not they've
actually pulled the trigger they're like
at that point now like the investment
committees are okay with it
um but nobody no very very very few
people are there with ethereum
um and that's just ethereum that's not
even trying to touch on like d5 or any
other alternative tokens or you know
thinking about things beyond ethereum
so it's still very very early days when
it comes to like institutions coming
into space and and
um and to your point yeah a lot of the
times there is usually one person
and they almost i would say 90 of the
time not always but like 90 of the time
they tend to see you younger um it's
kind of like that that saying it's like
um things that are created when you're
like 65 don't make sense
uh and are like unnatural things that
are created when you're 35
are uh you know innovative and things
that are
you know created when you're five or
just like the natural order of the thing
and you have the world
um to your point earlier right so like
um for like a 15 year old today like all
this stuff is just like how the world is
going to be
um but yeah i think most institutions
are not quite there yet i mean i think
the other thing that that's
worth noting here is like um
they're not irrational right like these
are really smart people
and part of what happens behind the
scenes is like how these decisions get
made
and so like i think like i didn't know
this before i became an investor is like
the process by which an institution
decides to make an investment decision
a is a pretty heavy lift the bigger the
organization the heavier the lift
but also b it's really hard to unwind
and so you got to get
the entire organization there um and
there's a lot of like
um principal agent risk mixed in which
is you know like
are am i gonna be the person that puts
my neck out to do this
and like why am i gonna do that inside
this organization and so you either have
to have people who really really really
believe
um or there has to be some sort of
catalyst and and this is where i think
like
covet really changed a lot like
everybody sort of realized that if we're
going to a zero interest rate world
in in usd dollars like usd denominated
world like you're the euro is already
there
um then if you have like yield targets
if you're trying to make
seven percent a year like how are you
gonna do that um
and so all of a sudden people are open
to the idea because kind of they have to
be
um and so i think it's inevitable but
yeah it's still very early days for
anything that's that's not bitcoin
is there anything that you think uh
maybe is getting tons of attention and a
lot of
people are flocking whether there's uh
individual like intellectual capital or
financial capital that maybe you're not
as bullish on or something that you
think that you know
might not actually be sustainable yeah
well i think these things all go through
like a high cycle and i think hype
cycles are actually really important
i think a lot of people think hype
cycles are a bad thing but i think
they're necessary
it's just like you have to get the hype
cycle because the over investment is
what allows you to invest into stuff
that needs to like go mainstream across
the chasm and if you don't get the over
investment
the thing is never going to accrue
enough capital enough intention or
enough people to like really
make sense um and you see that there's
like this this whole like if anybody
wants to read carlotta perez there's
like a whole economic theory around like
why you need bubbles basically
um and it's an important part of like
innovation um
and and the thing that i think might be
in a little bit of a hype cycle right
now is essentially decentralized
infrastructure
um and in part it's i think you know the
people who are poor thinking developers
have experienced this themselves like
developers have been experiencing this
pain of like
oh i used to build on twitter and then
twitter shut down the api on me i used
to build on facebook and then facebook
shut down the api on me and kill my
business or you know we just we just saw
this last week right like setting aside
the politics of
of it all it kind of doesn't matter you
know what you think of parlor
the fact that like amazon can just shut
that thing off and apple and google can
just kick it out from the app store all
of a sudden i think the world kind of
woke up
and said wait a second this like five
companies control
whether or not you exist and if they
decide to take you out from the internet
like you don't exist
um and developers have been feeling that
pain for a long time and so now
everybody sort of i think is starting to
understand the pain is acute i kind of i
kind of liken it to the bear stearns
moment in 2008
or like if you were paying attention
bear stearns was a really big deal
um but the lehman moment was like a year
later and so i think we're now building
up to this like
bigger and bigger stuff is going to
happen and the world is waking up to the
idea that
literally you know five to ten companies
control whether or not you exist on the
internet and the internet is like your
life
um and so all of that is now a problem
statement but i don't think the
technology is quite where it needs to be
to actually solve the problem
yet it's getting there but it's not
quite there yet so i suspect what's
going to happen
is those things are maybe where defy was
in like 2015
where a lot of really smart people are
going to pour a lot of energy into it
which is great
but it's not going to quite work the way
that we need it to work yet um
and then there will be sort of a hype
cycle around that and probably flames
out and then on the other side of that
is where this stuff really starts to
work um but i suspect that's like
you know three four five years out i
don't think it's like in the next 12
months all of a sudden you can just
go truly decent like i think it's gonna
be hard to build like a truly
decentralized twitter that just works in
the next 12 months
yeah and it feels like we're now getting
to the point where
technologists understand like
centralization is a risk but maybe the
users don't yet
and so uh i keep talking about like the
develop it's the developer's
responsibility to build decentralized
systems
because the users don't care but at some
point in the future users will care
right it's kind of like encryption like
now users do care about encryption but
uh maybe 10 years ago like that wasn't
as big of a deal and so if you wanted to
protect your users you put encryption in
but
they weren't necessarily demanding it it
just feels like we're getting pulled in
that direction
um what's kind of your thought process
around like the regulatory response to
all this so like
you know you and i sit down and we're
super bullish and we get really excited
and we're like oh my god bitcoin's going
to like
you know have this great ascent uh
there's all these decentralized systems
like
you know the internet is the the king um
and there's a lot of regulators who are
like okay crazy guys like chill out uh
that world's never gonna happen right
like
we don't want that to happen um like who
wins essentially right or
where is it actually there's coexistence
like maybe there isn't such a
competition it is literally just
coexistence like how do you think
through that
yeah it's a really great question i
spend a lot of time thinking about this
and and have spent actually a fair
amount of time talking to
um to regulators and policy folks and
and
um and people in the intelligence
community as well um in law enforcement
and
and i think um you know if
you have to sort of think through it i
think game theoretically which is like
who are the actors and what are
incentives and what does that mean
and i think if there were only two
actors in the mix if it was just like
the us government
and and the crypto people it would
probably play out
sort of straightforwardly which is like
hey we don't really like this like
you know maybe we'll shut it down but
there's a third actor in the mix here
which is the chinese government
and i think the chinese government
actually is the like hyper rational
like amazing i mean like they're so
impressive in how they managed to use
technology um you know again setting
aside what you think they do with the
technology just their ability to use
technology is that
they're the best government in the world
at this and so
what are they doing well what the
chinese government has done is they
basically said you know what we're gonna
let the supply
chain for bitcoin exist here like yeah
make the asics that's great
uh run them here like run your mining
pools here that's awesome we love that
um but you know what we don't really
love people buying a lot of this stuff
so we're gonna make sure that like
that's pretty much under our control
and so they hit this like perfect sweet
spot where they like have influence over
this stuff they're building capacity
like
um president xi said we're gonna invest
a bunch in blockchain infrastructure
we're gonna subsidize that we have the
blockchain network happening
they're investing in their dc ep system
their digital currency electronic
payment system which is a blockchain
based
uh central bank digital currency and
then they're going to take that
which now lets them have truly digital
cash and they're going to push it
through the belt and road so they're
investing trillions of dollars
um you know to for these strategic
initiatives in developing markets um
from all the way from singapore to sri
lanka to to
east africa into the gulf and into
europe and they're just going to push it
through there and so all of a sudden
you know if you're doing any kind of
international trade if you're doing any
kind of goods transfers if you're doing
any financial transactions all of a
sudden
you have this way better system now it's
not like the old school 1970s fedwire
system
um that takes you know weeks for your
cash to show up where you need because
it has to go through three hops and
three different people need to settle
along the way uh it's instant um and
that's pretty compelling right if you're
trying to do business that's pretty
compelling and if your
largest trading partner says hey why
don't we use this this platform
that's even more compelling and so
that's kind of what's happening that's
the third actor is now
the the chinese government could
actually become the platform on which
like international trade is settled
um and if you're the us government that
is actually a much bigger challenge than
crypto
like if if i'm if i'm the us government
if i'm treasury if i'm
um you know fencing if i'm um the cia
like anybody in government actually
needs to be thinking about
how how do we operate in a world where
today one of the best tools for us
national security is the fact that the
us dollar is the reserve currency of the
world
and um if that gets weakened and there's
an entire system
that allows countries to circumvent that
what does that mean for us
and that is a pretty existential threat
so you say okay well that's a given
that's happening that's not like
crypto you know paranoia like literally
you can just go read like that's
literally the
chinese government is very transparent
about this um and so
if that's what's happening what do you
do if you're the government if you're
the us government
and you kind of have two options you can
either try to like compete with them
head on
and if you try to do that i think you
fail like healthcare.gov you know
the history of the us government writing
technology in like the last 20 years is
not good
so they're going to try and they should
like you should modernize these
modernize these systems
but you're already seven years behind
and you don't have a great track record
so i don't think you win if you do that
but how do you win if you're a startup
person like you immediately start
thinking about like
startup 101 is just like what is the
judo move here like what is the thing
that you can do
that the other person just can't do
structurally right so like snap
one um in large part because they just
did the opposite of facebook
like you open up the phone and it was a
camera instead of a feed there was no
permanent identity
um you know it was all ephemeral and
facebook was entirely about you know
permanent identity it's just like they
did the opposite of facebook in so many
ways and that's why facebook has such a
hard time with it
um and so what do you need to do if
you're the us government i would argue
you actually need to embrace crypto
because crypto is the one thing that the
chinese government will not
do like they don't want capital to leave
china and not be in their control
they don't want to give away privacy i
mean crypto is about privacy and
self-sovereign
and censorship resistance like all of
the things that make
crypto work or all of the things that
the chinese government doesn't want to
do
so i think if you're the us government
you like double down on crypto actually
you like really embrace it and you say
this is actually our offensive tool like
we're going to do all the stuff we need
to do to upgrade our infrastructure and
try to compete
um but let's like actually embrace u.s
backed stable coins like let's get usdc
um and cello dollars and and libra you
know or dm dollars or whatever
let's just get that everywhere let's get
that into the developing world because
that's that's reinforcing the network
effect of the us dollar
um let's actually embrace bitcoin let's
actually make sure that all the crypto
interest you know innovation that's
happening happens in american companies
and happens
in american banks and happens in
american you know happens on shore
basically instead of pushing it out
to regions of the world where where
other governments have more influence so
it's maybe a little counterintuitive on
the surface but i actually think like
the game theory optimal move for the us
government
is to double down on crypto and really
embrace it because that's actually how
you can you can have a shot against
competing as the chinese government
without which i think i think you're
really going to struggle with us
government i think
at least in my conversations um i think
there are enough people in government
that actually get that so there's
actually a contingent of people inside
the u.s government
across all of these different groups
that get that and are trying to make
that case right now
i could not agree more i think that uh
the whole idea of like the government's
gonna ban
it is the exact kind of uh intuitiveness
that ends up not coming to fruition
and uh it's the counterintuitive move of
no the first countries to embrace this
actually win
um and although the united states is
very good at sometimes getting in its
way
uh i do think that that is where we're
going to end up and
you're you know alluding to everything
from there's congressmen there's
senators there's people up and down the
us government that i think are uh
are kind of starting to wake up to this
and uh as somebody said to me
um in a very blunt way they said look uh
all
old people die eventually and they're
replaced by younger people and so the
odds that
a president in the future is a bitcoiner
uh or a crypto person is like very high
and that's just uh
maybe 20 years from now but like that
happens at some point right it's just
naturally if you grew up like there's
people who now are assuming positions of
power and influence in the
uh government that grew up with a cell
phone in their hand right they're just
starting and so 20 years from now like
almost everyone will be that way
so it's pretty interesting uh before we
get into rapid fire questions to wrap up
um what is kind of your sweet spot from
an investment standpoint so for founders
or people who are building
uh in the crypto ecosystem uh what kind
of what are you looking for both from a
thematic standpoint and also from like a
stage of
uh the company or the project yeah uh
we're seed and series a investors um
we'll do tokens we'll do crypto networks
we'll do hybrid we'll do equity so we'll
kind of do everything
but our sweet spot is like you know a
couple of people and an idea
um and and maybe a prototype uh because
we're builders and we kind of know how
to take we've seen a lot of companies
inside crypto and outside
um go from from nothing to something to
you know a couple billion dollars to an
ipo like we've seen that whole life
cycle
um and so in the early stages where we
can be the most helpful and that's where
we add the most value so that's where we
focus
um in terms of sectors and stuff it goes
back to kind of what we're talking about
before
like there's a bunch of stuff that that
we have conviction on things like you
know defy
uh and decentralized infrastructure
frankly um we think it will happen
um but the stuff that gets us really
excited is
like when you meet with a founder and
you walk out of the meeting
saying well i went into the meeting
believing x and i walked out of the
meeting believing not x like that person
actually turned upside down
like what i think about the world that's
the kind of person that you you just bet
on you're just like okay like i had some
long-held belief about the world and you
actually changed that
um you found something you figured out
something that's true about the world
that most people think
is not true um and when you find
something like that you're just like
okay take all my money
uh and that doesn't happen that often
but those are the people that like we
love working with it's just like you
find one of those people and you're just
like cool take all the money
i love it that is a fantastic thesis uh
alright i got three questions for you
and then you'll get to ask me one to
finish up the first is what's the most
important book you've ever read
oh we did this before it's still the
bible
second question is a a new one what
is your sleep routine our friends over
at eight sleep
have officially sponsored this question
now because they know i'm a big sleep
nut
and i try to get at least eight if not
nine hours a night what uh
what would you say is your sleep routine
uh i would say my sleep routine is
terrible i don't have one
um we have we have a little baby and so
i don't get it i don't get my sleep
routine is terrible
i wish i had a plateau how old is the
baby
uh he's eight months old now so he's
starting to settle in okay so he so
here's the uh the three answers that i
get one is i work too much
two is uh i'm religious about my sleep
and i already haven't eat sleep and it's
amazing
or three is i have a young child and
whenever somebody says i have a young
child it's immediately known just like
there is no sleep schedule it's horrible
you're lucky that i showed up here and
like showered before i came
yeah no it's it's uh it's hard but it's
it's wonderful in all sorts of other
ways a plus plus like would recommend
everybody should have children it's
great uh
last question is uh aliens are you still
believing are we do we have any change
of opinion
uh from a galactic federation or
whatever other crazy ufo stuff that's uh
starting to come out i'm still a
believer i don't know have you been
tracking like the david favor stuff with
like tic tac and
and gimbal and all that stuff and then
uh
which was like the harvard guy is
convinced it was a spaceship even
tracking all this
yeah so i um people naturally send me
everything
uh and so all the things you just
mentioned yes the one that i recently
saw that i have not looked at yet
is uh i guess rogan had some guy on who
claims that he might have been abducted
by a ufo or something
oh really and supposedly from what i
gleaned again i
didn't listen yet but what i saw online
was uh
he and his friends went into the woods
there's this big white light
something happened he basically blacked
out he came too
many days later his friends ran away
they've all taken polygraph tests like
multiple times throughout the years and
they all have the exact same story they
all pass the polygraphs every time
uh and so like i'll have to listen to
kind of all the details but like
you know if that stuff starts to happen
where it's like you know same story for
20 years
polygraphs are passed like i don't know
man it's uh
you you start to wonder you know what
what's really going on
have you um have you heard of you know
the betty and and uh
barney hill abduction from the 1960s it
was like 1964 or something it's like a
really famous one
yeah so it's um it was like the first
modern
uh ufo abduction that kind of like went
into the press and so it's like the
first modern one
but it turns out um that guy's
granddaughter is an mma fighter
um and so she's like just a super
interesting person so if you want to
guess to like talk about
i like alien stuff but also it's just
like a super interesting person she's
like a legit mma fighter too
be like my grandfather got abducted by
aliens and now i beat people up in the
ring
it's super interesting because i started
tweeting about it um a couple days ago
and she i think she's gonna do like some
she's she's gonna talk about her
grandparents or something and all the
stories that they told her about this
stuff
that's crazy okay i'll definitely go
check that out uh you get asked me one
question to finish up what you got for
me
uh what are you most looking forward to
in 2021
getting back to not putting air quotes
normal like just you know kind of
getting
vaccines done masks open up the
businesses just
just get back to the closest semblance
we possibly can
of normal you know you know many people
would debate like i don't know if
we ever lived in a normal world so like
are we you know where are we going back
to
uh but but just i think a lot of the the
additional obstacles and hardships that
people are facing like just get over
that stuff
yeah yeah that'll be nice to get back to
normal whatever that is now the new
normal
for sure where can we send people to
find you on the internet or find out
more about electric
yeah just uh follow me on twitter
adavitrol um electric's pretty easy to
find it's electriccapital.com
awesome well listen thank you so much
for doing this let's do it again in the
future
yeah look forward